[Música]
en nuestra casa desayunábamos
almorzábamos y cenábamos política desde
muy pequeña veía que en mi casa las
fiestas eran tertulias políticas música
no porque sino no se podía conversar y
por eso probablemente es que desde
chiquilla tuve inquietudes de las
cuestiones políticas no solo de costa
rica sino del mundo como mafalda
últimamente recientemente hemos
escuchado todos las frases el modelo
está agotado el capitalismo produce
desigualdad y yo me preguntaba
angustiada será que tenemos que
erradicar la globalización o erradicar
el capitalismo será eso posible si es
que eso es lo que necesitamos
el movimiento 'occupy wall street' es
emblemático de esa angustia por la
creciente desigualdad como lo fue
también la campaña de bernie sanders en
los eeuu y la obra de thomas piketty en
europa lo que postulaban o postulan es
que la gran desigualdad se debe a la
concentración del poder y el capital en
unos pocos en ese 1% y que para
combatirla lo que hay que hacer es
distribuir la renta entre los que más
tienen hacia los que menos tienen
eso me sonaba siempre razonable y lógico
pero yo decía hay algo más hay algo en
la manera en que estamos funcionando en
que los estados y las instituciones de
los gobiernos no están haciendo bien su
trabajo esto tiene que ir más allá
incluso de la cuestión económica será
que hay una crisis y que la democracia
está agotada será que los estados tienen
que ir desapareciendo me preguntaba
pues yo empecé a leer a hararé y también
así ven penca y me gustaba mucho el
abordaje científico histórico y
holístico que traían sus libros y sus
obras en defensa de la ilustración de
steven ven acá la obra postula que la
tecnología y la globalización entre
otros aspectos son más bien causa de
mayor crecimiento económico de mayor
progreso e incluso de mayor prosperidad
por supuesto se admite que hay una mayor
y creciente desigualdad en las últimas
décadas pero la clave no es
necesariamente o exclusivamente la
distribución de la renta cualquier
solución tiene que venir con la ciencia
los datos y la razón por eso defiende la
ilustración y por eso en su obra en
combate todos los mitos con data y con
yo entonces empecé a pensar
qué diría platón en su libro la
repubblica lo que platón decía es que el
estado justo es cuando los gobernantes
gobiernan o dan órdenes en beneficio de
los gobernados no en beneficio propio
como estamos nosotros en costa rica las
instituciones están cumpliendo ese rol
están gobernando para los ciudadanos
pues sabemos desde hace algunos años
gracias a múltiples diagnósticos
incluyendo el estado de la nación
también los informes de la contraloría
general de la república que no están así
que necesitamos
reformar muchas cosas y yo pienso en
realidad la globalización es como el mar
en realidad en ese mar que es la
globalización fluyen libremente la
inversión el capital la ciencia el
conocimiento la tecnología la cultura y
la clave es como los estados como los
diferentes países logran que lo que
fluye en ese mar le llegue a todos los
habitantes sin ahogar los
y yo pienso
si la globalización es el mar los
estados entonces tienen que comportarse
como anémonas de mar
las anémonas se mueven con el movimiento
del mar pero no andan bailando por todos
lados tienen un pie o una pata que
sólidamente las afirma en un lugar en
una posición las anémonas son múltiples
de diferentes colores y tamaños
dependiendo donde habitan como los
estados
y pienso entonces que las instituciones
de los estados tienen que ir reformando
se conforme la época lo amerita conforme
la ciencia la tecnología y toda la
evidencia va requiriendo esas reformas
así como las anémonas los estados tienen
que tener cierta solidez tienen que dar
seguridad tienen que dar certeza pero
también como las anémonas tienen que
permitir que sus instituciones vayan
amoldándose como el movimiento de las
patas y ojo la función también de un
estado justo es proteger a los
vulnerables de los abusos que existen en
el sistema en el capitalismo porque hay
depredadores en este mar y las anémonas
lo que hacen es no solo usar un veneno
contra esos depredadores sino que a lo
largo de la vida van modificando ese
veneno para sobrevivir y así tienen que
funcionar los estados
si antes en una época sea varias décadas
era necesario abrir una sucursal de un
banco en cada cantón para asegurar la
garantía de acceso al crédito a todos
los habitantes hoy lo más importante es
el acceso al simple móvil el acceso al
teléfono el acceso a la tecnología el
acceso al conocimiento
si antes pensábamos que la bolsa era
solo para los magnates hoy nos damos
cuenta que mediante las inversiones
bursátiles también el público puede
invertir para apoyar emprendimientos y
así vamos modificando nuestro estado en
nuestras instituciones usando la
evidencia usando la tecnología
preguntándonos a quién debo beneficiar
cuáles son los efectos deseados y no
deseados de una reforma
y por eso es que las instituciones del
estado no pueden ser concebidas como
muros de sólidos ladrillos porque
primero porque ese mar no vas no va a
entrar a todos nuestros habitantes los
más vulnerables sobre todo no van a
tener acceso a todo lo que trae la
globalización a todos los beneficios si
nos podemos sentir protegidos pero en
realidad lo que estamos haciendo es
limitando nos ese no es la lógica de un
estado de anémona eso es un estado
rígido inflexible que se van kilos ando
y se va capturando y eso es muy
peligroso
por eso nosotros debemos sentirnos
sumamente orgullosos de un hito
histórico que fue nuestra incorporación
o más bien la invitación de parte de los
miembros de la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico la
ocde son sólo 37 miembros y nos han
invitado a ser el número 38 esa
organización lo que postula es que el
estado tiene que tener un espíritu
riguroso y reformista sobre la base de
evidencia nos dimos cuenta gracias a
este proceso y también desde hace ya
bastante tiempo que era necesario
reformar muchas leyes
reformamos más de 14 leyes las adecuamos
a los estándares internacionales y cinco
de ellas en el sistema financiero
también hicimos reformas administrativas
en áreas como por ejemplo de la
educación que tenemos que seguir
mejorando para no dejar a nadie atrás en
área también de gobierno y gobernanza de
las empresas del estado para dar mayor
rendimiento y mayor rendición de cuentas
esas reformas demuestran que si costa
rica quiere costa rica puede ser mejor y
ese paso importante que hemos tomado lo
tenemos que seguir tomando porque es una
en un eslabón en una serie de cadenas de
nuestros gobernantes y las decisiones
valientes que han tomado desde el siglo
19 nosotros hemos construido gracias a
esas decisiones un modelo de
sostenibilidad que es ejemplar
y en retrospectiva nos vamos a dar
cuenta que el ingreso a la voz fue una
de esas decisiones valientes y sobre
todo que es un nutriente fenomenal para
esa anemia que es nuestro estado para
que esa anémonas siga cumpliendo su rol
en el ecosistema de este mar muchas
gracias
[Música]